hello everyone and welcome to our
webinar on the upcoming ITIL for
overhaul
now the first major update since 2007 is
coming this quarter to ITIL that's the
IT infrastructure library from acts
woves now in this hour we're going to be
telling you what you need to know about
this impending update which is really
more like an overhaul to ITIL that's the
popular framework of best practices for
delivering IT services I'm Dan bavander
I'm simple Aaron's director training
research and your moderator today and
it's my pleasure to introduce you to our
esteemed guest Manuel Lloyd Manuel is a
certified 800 is the CIO consultant
entrepreneur as well as a computing
platform inventor
he's also processed expert who
specializes in IT governance legislative
compliance operational efficiency and
cybersecurity Manuel has more than 20
years of IT service and management
industry experience partnering with
global leaders including GE IBM HP and
other businesses including education
government entities he's also course
adviser for simply learned providing the
thought leadership and business insights
for the IT service and architecture
training curriculum here so once again
Manuel it's great to have you here well
thanks Dan is great to be here to get
this conversation started here's a
preview of what Manuel will be talking
about today
so Manuel take it away thanks Dan
hello everyone I hope you having a great
day North Carolina there's cold one day
and hot the next day so if I cough I
apologize the weather is really crazy
here excuse me there we go so today's
agenda we're going to cover ITIL today
version 3 and by the way that word
version is probably going to disappear
it's just going to be ITIL 4 and then
the next iteration so we're going to
also talk about what's changing from
ITIL version 3 to ITIL 4 we're going to
talk about understanding the ITIL 4
journey and try to help you along the
way and we're going to also talk about
the deep dive into you ITIL Forrester
Kayson scheme will die that is and
what's the best approach for you in
particular because it just depends on
what you're trying to do and I'll get
into the different schemes as we go as
Dan mention we're going to have a Q&A
session my opening slide here talks
about infrastructure and infrastructure
in itself is hardware software and
facilities or buildings whatever you
want to call it and many companies today
if you talk with your CFO you talk with
your financial person they're trying to
move away from capex or capital
expenditures to op X or operational
expenditures which is naming cloud and
as a service type of services and ITIL
will be at the forefront of both however
it's going to be more optics than ever
before and continuing in that stead I
cannot see data centers growing for your
individual IT departments I can see data
centers growing as a service from like a
Google recently Google just made a
purchase of a cloud-based services where
you can migrate your cloud systems you
know Dell and EMC you know you look at
Amazon and Microsoft is moving into the
Magic Quadrant up into the right below
Amazon so everyone's getting into that
game because it's the future you know
data lines are getting faster there I
even have an invention that's working
with DARPA about faster data plans for
government's security mobile
technologies are becoming the primary
device you know when you when you look
at something you're probably look at
your mobile phone first and
cybersecurity is a key factor and Axel
OSA is getting this thing right because
we're talking about cyber security but
cyber resilience is more of what we're
looking for
amongst my peers at least what we're
talking about because the resilience to
changes the resilience to all of these
hack hacking events going on and things
of that nature it's not a matter of if
it's a matter of win and just a little
side
note their if you're looking at axle
load for cyber resilience they have a
scheme called resilient you can take a
look at that when you get a moment so
what does this mean for you I to a
professional out there well I took
professional either continuous training
and learning and upkeep of their ITIL
certification scheme and in the
community of itself
people are requiring that their
framework of choice remain aligned with
modernized technology such as digital in
AI well we're talking about the fourth
Industrial Revolution and the first
Industrial Revolution was at the 18th
century and when the fourth Industrial
Revolution which is digital cyber and
physical but all the lines are blurred
so the fourth Industrial Revolution is a
little bit different a lot of
Millennials understand it you know my
wife and I would have eight children
they were born with iPhones they don't
even know the rotary phone is excuse me
or even a dial pad phone you know you
know the buttons feel like because all
these phones today that they're not
giving me buttons you know so I believe
ITIL would be the framework of the
future for all things digital you know
you have the other frameworks Coben you
have lean you have agile devops and
things of that nature but I think ITIL
is the leader in this area
and will continue to be the leader it's
leaning and I'm excited about the ITIL
for changes because they're talking more
about you know software as a service
cloud services and things of that nature
zero clients mobile devices all of those
things are moving forward and very very
fast into our future why a question down
here
because istill has and will become the
lead to act as our bodies so in other
words what I mean there is frameworks
are built like bodies that have a head
to have on head legs and things of that
nature and everything has to be
autonomous it has to work together and
has to work as one and I personally
believe in my years of in the IT
industry that I feel is that body of
choice so let's talk about ITIL Version
three today many of you probably know
that this kind of started off as a
British Standard I want to stay with
British 15th out of the fifteen thousand
British Standard I forget what the exact
number is but in 1986 it got a spurt
right that time and as you can see on
this timeline here it goes all into
Version three and I think that is also
called 2011
some people called it up until 2012 2013
and here we are today in 2019 which is
this is really starting this year
there's some beta test last quarter and
some people actually got certified in
the foundation but this year is going to
be the year that if you don't have the
ice skill I'm sorry the ITIL up skills
that you need I would HIGHLY encourage
you to look at the cipa learn ITIL
course and I will be your course advisor
so if you ever have any questions you
can contact me I'm very easy going very
easy to reach you'll have that
information in a moment here as I go as
the saying goes ITIL is the best
practice a set of best practice
publications not really a standard it's
a guideline of a high key service
management it was owned by the Cabinet
Office party GM government axel OHS had
taken over at some point in time and I
got to tell you I was prior to Excellus
and I was after axel OC ever since Axl
Rose has taken over it's been splendid
it's been superior it's based on a
service life cycle of course and
consists of five life cycle stages
strategy service design service
transition service operation and
continual service improvement not a
continual service improvement it's kind
of something that ITIL is just kind of
took out just total quality management
in general but using these same
methodologies within an IT scheme if you
have worked in any kind of an IT
department for any period of time
continual service improvement
is something that senior leadership box
at because they want it done now they
want it done this quick they want it
done right away
and continue service improvement is a
process and you have to go through those
seven steps or whatever steps that you
go through for continual service of
permit they're also a set of
complimentary publications they're
really great you can get them online and
PDF format or the books themselves
I prefer online because in kind there's
a change you can you can have it right
away
so what's changing with ITIL for the new
updated I took guidance will be called
ITIL four we already know that this name
reflects like I said earlier the role
ITIL four will play in supporting
individuals and organizations to
navigate what axel else is calling the
fourth Industrial Revolution but not
just them it's about AI
it's about IOT it's about digital you
know it's about machine learning so many
things and axles you know I don't know
what they said I can imagine they said
on hey guys we have to be able to keep
up with modernized technology with with
our framework well as people start
looking in other places and and I gotta
say I'm a big big supporter of the ITIL
framework because I because of things
like that the leadership has taken it up
upon themselves to make sure that it
stays intact and in touch with what's
going on ITIL it's looking to be more
agile you know we're trying to get rid
of a waste we'll try to you know that's
lean but we're trying to be able to
adopt changes right away
I'll give you an acronym that I use for
ITIL and for really any other thing it's
called flash and if you're like me you
know I'll be 53 in July but I'm a big
comic book fan right so flash is one of
my favorite superheroes and I come up
with a acronym for that it's fast lean
agile secure and hassle-free that's what
you want at a framework that can be
agile that can be fast that can look to
the future that could be secure
and that could be modernized
organizations are looking to modernize
and it in every a company around the
world I would say and I don't have any
statistics on this but I would say in my
experience 90% of the business tools and
any company are IT related so how do you
manage these IT items these
configuration items and things of that
nature without some kind of a framework
that not only takes care of your legacy
systems but excellence has made it a
point to update I tilt
ITIL for to be able to take care of
modernized systems from here and in the
future ITIL evolved to provide an int in
IT / digital operating model covering
the full delivery and sustaining tech
enabled products and services I'm just
reading what it says here in guiding how
IT interfaces with and even leads the
water business strategy and I said I'm
reading this but I wrote this as well so
just these are my notes and the beauty
behind behind ITIL is that they can work
with any other framework ITIL is not
meant to replace everything else it can
work with koban it could work with lean
it can work with lean IT you can work
with agile it can work with just about
any framework that's out there and I
tell Fort will not be any different
because if they did do that it will go
against the principles of ITIL in itself
so I tell it's trying to be more agile
trying to be more lean and excellence is
trying to make sure that this happened
so yes the answer is yes you can use
ITIL with there is an interface between
ITIL 4 and Kovac so let's take a deep
dive into ideal for certification scheme
this is the meat of the matter so ITIL
there's a kind of mission before it's
going to still retain much of the core
elements of version 3 and much of the
existence will be recognized in ITIL 4
so don't throw your ITIL three
certifications in the trash don't throw
your hopes in the trash it's going to
build I feel for sort of build on that
so
Ethan looks like this and we'll break it
down in a minute you have your
foundation and yes you know you have to
take a foundation of course I think
simply when are we offering that then
there's two sides to it there's the edgy
ITIL Managing Partner or the MP and then
there's the ITIL strategic leader SL and
the MP portion you have a specialist
this is someone who creates deliver and
support an IT infrastructure you have
another specialist that drives
stakeholder value and high velocity IT
then you have your IPO strategist at
this you know you're going to take the
exam to begin your IT strategies
career where you direct plan and improve
and along that line there's a separate
certification you're going to take your
IT strategy and you're going to build
upon it when you direct plan and improve
and you're going to want to take your IT
leader certification or our course to
become an IT leader for digital and IT
strategy then of course you have your
master notice you don't see expert up
there okay but you have your master and
the beauty behind excellence is they're
trying to make this simple enough for
you to be able to integrate what you
already have and I'll talk about that in
a moment and move it into an ideal for
scheme the foundation will be available
on February 28th which is in a couple of
days this year it's the entry-level
certification offered for any learners a
general awareness of key components or
elements and terminology used in item
four so you'll be able to speak the
language and understand hopefully what's
going on the purpose of idea for
foundation is to introduce candidates to
the modern and IT Naval Service
Management and when they say modern
you're talking about these outsource
help desks you talk about many service
providers you talked about platform as a
service software as a service
infrastructure as a service and most of
those things are kind of going away
where there's just this big blob of
of storage for you to be able to put
your video games in to put your your
databases into and be able to kind of
self host and that's another beautiful
thing about idea force it's talking
about some of these things that are
modern now ITIL three never even mention
a managed service provider they talked
about service providers and purlins
external service providers but not in a
managed service provider a model so the
managing professional is the next level
it targets the practitioner working
within technology and digital teams
across businesses it you know I wrote a
formula a long time ago that talks about
the vertical horizontal relationships in
a business where you have the business
has a objective but each department
accounting you know finance and
accounting marketing sales operations
they all have their individual goals to
meet but they have to align with the
business and the IPO form model when you
look into a deeper it's looking to do
that so this is something that should
excite you hopefully to get you know
taking a foundation to the manage
managing professional because after
achieving a managing professional
Edition if you're interested you can
pursue the strategic leader stream and
you only need to complete the ITIL
strategic leader module any questions on
that before I move on okay then we can
come back to it as well the next thing
we'll talk about is the strategic leader
role which is going to recognize the
value of ITIL itself not just for IT
operations but for all digitally enabled
services everything ai you know machine
learning all of the different code now
that is being used to create automation
so all of those things are becoming is
what of becoming a strategic ITIL
strategically R is going to demonstrate
that you have a clear understanding of
how information technology is going
influence and direct business strategy
the biggest problem I've seen in large
companies and small is that ite is
looked at as a utility more so than a
strategy I so for if your company is
adopting it which I'm hoping that your
company does it's going to be a more
strategic partner in other words IT
should now have a seat at the table
where it didn't before in the shadow CIO
and I've even seen some CIOs get kicked
to the curb or sit at the kid the kids
table
you know I call that the CLO chief lays
a affair officers they don't want to
they just want it done they don't want
to get involved they want to hear about
all the IT the beauty behind ITIL though
is take it takes all of that IT language
and and speaks into business language so
that's the ideal strategic leader the
ideal leader digital and I teach a
strategic leader digital and IT strategy
module requires three years of
managerial experience as a prerequisite
along with the completion of the ITF or
foundation now this is good and I'm
going to tell you why because you can go
down to a Learning Center study a test
and pass it and that's what most of us
in the industry call a paper tiger well
I chose not interested in paper tigers
they want people who can apply the
principles of ITIL within an
organization organization to get the
complete value out of ITIL now when I
say value you're going to hear that a
lot in the ITIL 4 model you heard a lot
of 9003
version 3 but you hear a lot in ITIL 4
and here's what one concept that I've
been telling my customers is it's more
than just return on investment you want
that but you want to return on value so
instead of ROI of being the big speak
try to lean toward or just try to
understand me when I see the ROC or the
return on value because value is what is
key especially the information
technology ITIL for certification scheme
this is a quote from expose whilst cuz I
don't say whilst a while I feel for
retains many of the
core elements of ideal version three and
much of the existing guidance will be
recognized in parts of ideal for there
are no direct light for life modules
between the two certification schemes so
as you see the chart here and legend
eager both of each one of these real
quick the item mentioned partner in ITIL
strategic leader is a designation
achieved once complete once you've
completed all relevant
examinable modules in each stream the
future whatever color that is purple
looking examination modules toward ITIL
managed professionals and ITIL strategic
leader and the navy blue they're
examinable modules applicable to both
managing professional and ITIL strategic
leader and the last one is transition
model for ITIL version 3 version 3 IT
experts who have 17 credits or more to
get there
managing professional designation now
you notice I said that I kill experts
get their management festal designation
not their master you still have to take
exams for that and you still have to
have some other requirements in the
industry as well let's understand the
ITIL journey if we will if you're at
ITIL foundation 3 down you take the
ideal for foundation of course and then
you choose your path or you choose your
future so you can take ITIL version 3
intermediate practitioner or if your
there now you have three or four credits
there's two options the first option is
the IPO for foundation plus one
specialist strategist or leader then you
have option two which is 17 credits from
ITIL version 3 to take ITIL for NP or
Madison professional transition modules
we got that I know they're probably a
lot of questions on this part here we
had a lot of people registered for this
over two or three hundred I think so I
know this is this is really important so
I 2003 intermediate practitioner if
you're there with six or more credits
beyond foundation it's in your best in
my opinion
collect 17 total version three credits
to prepare for IPL for managing
professional and that that's my opinion
you can do what you want to but I think
that's in your best interest until
version three expert don't panic you can
still take the idea for transition model
as soon as it's released one side for MP
is achieved you can you know because you
still have to go through that excuse me
but once that is to achieve you can
pursue the ideal for strategic leader
and only need to take that tail for
strategic leader digital and strategy
bottle after completing ideal for
management professional and strategic
you can pursue master afterwards before
master release date will be announced at
a later date we don't know that when
that is but it will be released but
it'll take you some time to get to this
point anyway by that time it'll be
released and I think it will happen this
year you know a in touch with us that
simply learning myself and will be able
to let you know what's the best approach
for ITIL foundation level practitioners
I wish I could see a show of hands on
how many people are ITIL foundation you
have you taking the foundation course
for version 3 I recommend you take the
item for Foundation and we'll be able to
transition to the new certification
scheme don't try to hop you know you
want to get you want to absorb
everything you can from the very
beginning and this is like I think it's
February the 28th yeah a couple of days
I'd support foundation is scheduled to
be released so you want to sign up with
a company like you want to sign up with
simply learn to go ahead and take that
that that learning so you get your ideal
for course foundation the best approach
for the intermediate practitioners of
version 3 if you hold a low number of
credits beyond foundation there's two
options like I said before option one
where you're going to take the
foundation in another module in your
preferred area of interest becoming
either ITIL strategist or specialist or
leader option to you know achieve 17
credits from active version 3 to become
eligible to take
- I tell managing professional
transition and the active the examinable
module for ideal managing professional
narrative strategy leader strategic
leader are going to be available in h2
2019 so let's talk about what simply
learned has to offer in this area simply
learning you can correct me if I'm wrong
here anywhere damn to simply learn will
be launching IPO for foundation on
February 16 with in the self-paced will
be available from February 29th 2019 so
go ahead and sign up for that the simply
learn ITIL foundation course will be
available as both self-paced and online
classroom instruction you can pre-book
the exam vouchers from February 4th
however you can take the exams from
February 28th and onwards in
complimentary access to ITIL
version 3 foundation is self-paced so I
just want to wrap things up here and say
thanks again to Manuel for joining us
today so if you have any further
questions that didn't get addressed
during today's presentation please feel
free to tweet us at simply learn and
we'll get back to you and Manuel do you
have any contact information you'd like
people to know about you're a bunch of
people already hit me up on LinkedIn so
that's good and but at at mwl consulting
on twitter and manuel debbie lloyd on
linkedin but I got to tell you it would
do my heart so good if you took all your
courses especially for ITIL that's
simply learned so I can stay in touch
with you and be this person you can
touch and and and talk to with you when
you're going through your journey and I
want to be a part of that with you and
simply them learn what's of the
apartment so please please all the
typical Ernie thanks Manuel and that's
one of the great advantages of this is
that the the when you're when you're
training was simpler you know that there
are experts behind what you're learning
and not just someone who conglomerated a
bunch of information for you to learn
from these
these are real people waiting to help
you 24 hours a day so thank you again
everyone for joining us and thank you
especially thanks again for joining us
[Music]